It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
当前正值授粉高峰期，我的业务也在飞速发展。为了保证蜜蜂源源不断地采蜜，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢再忙碌，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐起价仅为每月 35 美元。这可真是一个不会错过的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。需加收税费和政府规费。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Sesame Street, the show that has entertained and educated generations of children, is now in its 54th season. The program has kept pace with the times. Once primarily known for focusing on ABCs and 123s, Sesame Street has turned its attention over the years to many other topics that touch on children's lives, from grief to race and racism to COVID-19. Last year, Sesame Workshop announced a new focus on the emotional
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高流量期间不会受到数据流量降速的影响。《芝麻街》这部为几代儿童带来欢乐与教育的节目，目前已迎来第 54 季。该节目一直与时俱进。曾经以专注于 ABC 和 123 闻名的《芝麻街》多年来已将注意力转向了许多触及儿童生活的其他主题，从悲伤、种族与种族主义到新冠肺炎。去年，芝麻街工作室宣布将重点转向幼儿及其家庭的
well-being of young children and their families. Since then, they've been working with APA and other partners to develop materials to teach young kids about how to understand and manage their feelings. Today, we're going to talk with a psychologist who's worked at Sesame Street for decades about why a focus on young kids' emotional well-being is needed right now, how the show translates complicated concepts into stories that young kids can connect with, the research that underpins all the content on Sesame Street and what's behind the program's enduring success. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
心理健康。从那时起，他们一直与美国心理协会（APA）及其他合作伙伴合作开发材料，教导幼儿如何理解和管理自己的情绪。今天，我们将与一位在《芝麻街》工作了几十年的心理学家进行交谈，探讨为什么现在需要关注幼儿的心理健康、该节目如何将复杂的概念转化为幼儿能够产生共鸣的故事、《芝麻街》所有内容背后的研究支撑是什么，以及该节目持久成功的秘诀。欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Rosemary Trilio, a developmental and child psychologist and senior vice president of curriculum and content at Sesame Workshop where she has worked since 1997. She oversees all content and curriculum development for Sesame Street and other shows produced by Sesame Workshop. Dr. Trulio has written numerous articles published in Child and Developmental Psychology journals and presented her work at national and international conferences. She's author of the book, Ready for School, a Parents Guide to Playful Learning for Children Ages 2 to 5, and co-editor of G is for Growing, 30 years of research on Children and Sesame Street.
我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是罗丝玛丽·特里利奥博士（Dr. Rosemary Trulio），她是一位发展和儿童心理学家，也是芝麻街工作室（Sesame Workshop）课程与内容高级副总裁，自 1997 年以来一直在该机构工作。她负责监督《芝麻街》以及芝麻街工作室制作的其他节目的所有内容和课程开发。特里利奥博士撰写了大量发表在儿童和发展心理学期刊上的文章，并在国内和国际会议上发表了她的研究成果。她是《准备上学：2至5岁儿童趣味学习家长指南》（Ready for School, a Parents Guide to Playful Learning for Children Ages 2 to 5）一书的作者，也是《G代表成长：儿童与芝麻街研究30年》（G is for Growing, 30 years of research on Children and Sesame Street）的共同主编。
She has appeared on television and radio programs, including the Today's Show, Good Morning America, NPR's Life Kit for Parents, and All Things Considered, talking about Sesame Street and offering research-based advice on children and parenting. Dr. Trulio, thank you for joining me today. Oh, thank you, Kim. It's a pleasure to be talking with you today. I mentioned in the intro that Sesame Workshop announced a multi-year commitment to focusing on children's emotional well-being last year. Why did you decide that this was such an important topic to focus on right now? It's a very important topic because we have a global mental health crisis. And Sesame from its inception has always been there to help children and the caregivers and adults in their lives to help them build what we call these foundational skills to get them ready for school and to get them ready for life. So Sesame Street is driven by what we call a whole child curriculum. So we're dealing with all aspects of child development.
她曾出现在电视和广播节目中，包括《今日秀》（Today's Show）、《早安美国》（Good Morning America）、美国国家公共电台（NPR）的《父母生活指南》（Life Kit for Parents）以及《所有事情考虑》（All Things Considered），谈论《芝麻街》并提供基于研究的儿童及育儿建议。特里利奥博士，非常感谢您今天能来。哦，谢谢你，金。很高兴今天能与你交谈。我在开场白中提到，芝麻街工作室去年宣布了一项为期数年的承诺，重点关注儿童的心理健康。你们为什么认为这是一个现在必须重点关注的如此重要的话题？这是一个非常重要的话题，因为我们面临着全球心理健康危机。而《芝麻街》自创立以来，一直致力于帮助儿童以及他们生活中的看护人和成年人，帮助他们建立我们所谓的这些基础技能，让他们为上学做好准备，为生活做好准备。因此，《芝麻街》是由我们所谓的全人教育课程驱动的。所以我们正在处理儿童发展的各个方面。
They're academic skills, their social emotional skills, their health needs. And we're very much in tune to what is going on in terms of the latest research, the best practices, as well as what's going on in our society. So when it was announced that there's a global health crisis, which was there before the pandemic, but just got exacerbated with the pandemic, that we decided, because we always have a curriculum focus every year, every year. And we decided that we can make a difference in provide foundational information to help build the foundation of what we're calling. emotional well-being. How do you teach young children about a complicated topic like emotional well-being? How is it different from developing content for older children or adults? Well, we have to keep in mind that we're talking to an audience that ranges from ages 2 to age 5. And we need to make sure that the content is meaningful and relevant to them as well as engaging for them. Because we know that those are critical factors to keep children paying attention to the messages, but also when
包括他们的学业技能、社交情感技能、健康需求。我们非常密切地关注最新研究、最佳实践以及我们社会中正在发生的事情。因此，当宣布存在全球健康危机时——这种危机在疫情之前就已经存在，但在疫情期间进一步加剧——我们决定，由于我们每年都有一个课程重点，每年都有，我们决定我们可以发挥作用，提供基础信息，帮助奠定我们所谓的心理健康的基础。你如何向幼儿教授像心理健康这样复杂的话题？这与为年龄较大的儿童或成年人开发内容有什么不同？嗯，我们必须记住，我们的受众年龄在 2 岁到 5 岁之间。我们需要确保内容对他们来说既有意义、相关，又具有吸引力。因为我们知道，这些是让儿童保持对信息关注的关键因素，而且当他们与内容互动时，
they're engaged with content, it helps with the comprehension. So we make sure that our goals are developmentally appropriate, but we never, ever talk down to children. So we want to make sure that the stories have meaning in their lives. And we give them what we call the vocabulary. So we focused a lot on the vocabulary for emotional awareness. Because we know with really young children, they have a range of big feelings, but they don't have the words to express these feelings. And the adults in their lives also have to remind them of the nuances in terms of the vocabulary. So angry versus frustrated versus disappointed and not be afraid to use these big words, but to define them in the moment of the scenario that they're feeling. So they have an understanding of the
这也有助于理解。因此，我们确保我们的目标在发展上是适龄的，但我们绝不以居高临下的态度对儿童说话。所以我们要确保这些故事在他们的生活中具有意义。我们赋予他们我们所谓的词汇。因此，我们非常关注情绪意识的词汇。因为我们知道，对于非常小的儿童来说，他们有一系列强烈的情感，但他们没有表达这些生动的词汇。他们生活中的成年人也必须提醒他们词汇方面的细微差别。所以是生气与沮丧与失望的区别，并且不要害怕使用这些大词，而是在他们感受到这些情绪的场景当下定义这些词。这样他们就能理解
meaningfulness of that word. And when you're dealing with audiovisual content, make sure that there's a term that we use is say and see. Make sure that the visuals are in tune to what they're hearing and gestures. Gestures are really important in terms of comprehension. So as you could hear me saying, we do a lot of research. We are calling from the academic research that's coming from the learning sciences, and we also engage in our own what we call formative research because even though I have a doctorate in developmental psychology, I'm constantly
这个词的含义。当你在处理视听内容时，确保有一个我们使用的术语叫“说和看”（say and see）。确保视觉效果与他们所听到的内容和手势相契合。手势对于理解非常重要。正如你所听到的，我们做了大量的研究。我们借鉴了来自学习科学的学术研究，我们还参与了我们自己所谓的形成性研究，因为即使我拥有发展心理学博士学位，我也在不断地
learning from children. They're the real experts. I may think this is going to work, but then we show children and they're telling us what's working for them. Right. One of your newest videos is about feelings helpers. It's a way of introducing children to the idea of therapy and mental health professionals. I'm a special helper too. Sophia is, really? Cool. But where's your costume? This is my costume. This is what I wear when I do my job. I am a therapist, a counselor.
从儿童身上学习。他们才是真正的专家。我可能认为这会行之有效，但当我们向儿童展示时，他们会告诉我们什么对他们有用。没错。你的最新视频之一是关于“情绪助手”。这是一种向儿童介绍治疗和心理健康专业人员概念的方法。我也是一个特别的助手。索菲亚也是，真的吗？太酷了。但是你的服装呢？这是我的服装。这就是我做这份工作时穿的衣服。我是一名治疗师，一名咨询师。
I'm a feelings helper. Can you tell us about that? How did you come up with the idea of feelings helpers? I'm really glad you asked me that question. When we start a new initiative for a new season of content, both show content and also we have a tremendous. amount of content, free resources on our website. So sesame street.org in this particular initiative, it's backslash mental health. And these resources are there for parents and caregivers and educators to use. But we always start with what we call an advisory curriculum seminar. And that's
我是一个情绪助手。你能给我们讲讲这个吗？你们是怎么想到“情绪助手”这个主意的？我很高兴你问我这个问题。当我们为一个新季度的内容（包括节目内容以及我们拥有的大量内容、网站上的免费资源）启动一项新倡议时，比如 sesame street.org，在这个特定的倡议中，是斜杠 mental health（心理健康）。这些资源供家长、看护人和教育工作者使用。但我们总是从我们所谓的顾问课程研讨会开始。这就是
where we bring in the experts to help us, help us figure out what goals should we focus on and then how to move forward in terms of content creation. So as I said, we have a mental health crisis. And for the most part, we're just focusing on emotional well-being, which are these foundational skills. So that is emotional awareness, social connections, mind-body connections, and compassionate mindset. We could talk about these four domains later. But on the website, we also wanted to bring attention to destigmatize mental health in terms of there are times in children's lives that these basic foundational skills aren't enough, that their big feelings are impeding with their everyday moments or things that they want to do, such as anxiety, right?
我们邀请专家来帮助我们弄清楚我们应该关注哪些目标，然后如何在内容创作方面继续推进。正如我所说，我们面临着心理健康危机。而且在很大程度上，我们只是专注于心理健康，也就是这些基础技能。这就是情感意识、社交连接、身心连接和同理心思维。我们稍后可以讨论这四个领域。但在网站上，我们也想引起人们对消除心理健康污名化的关注，即在儿童生活中，有时这些基本的基础技能是不够的，他们的强烈情感会阻碍他们的日常生活或他们想要做的事情，例如焦虑，对吧？
we want parents and caregivers and educators to know that it is okay to then get additional help. Now, children are used to go into the pediatrician, they go to the doctor, but what do you call the person who is helping them with their big feelings? And one of the advisors said, you know, we don't want to call them therapists or counselors. What does that mean for a child? So we're going to call them feelings helpers. These are special people who help us have a better understanding of what the emotions that are overwhelming and taking over. More importantly, what are the strategies to help be with those big feelings when they come up?
我们希望家长、看护人和教育工作者知道，寻求额外的帮助是可以的。现在，儿童习惯去看儿科医生，他们去看医生，但你如何称呼那个帮助他们应对强烈情感的人呢？其中一位顾问说，你知道，我们不想称他们为治疗师或咨询师。这对一个儿童意味着什么？所以我们要称他们为“情绪助手”。这些是特殊的人，他们帮助我们更好地理解那些令人不知所措并接管情绪的含义。更重要的是，当这些强烈情感出现时，有哪些策略可以帮助我们与这些情感相处？
And it's really important sometimes to talk to someone who is skilled in helping them. And they are your counselors and your mental health professionals. But for children, they're feelings helpers. Can you tell us a little bit more about your role at Sesame Workshop? What do you do as the vice president of curriculum and content? Are you convening these groups or reviewing the science or a little of everything? Okay. So as the senior vice president for curriculum and content, it's my responsibility to help our organization figure out what are we going to focus on.
有时与一个擅长帮助他们的人交谈真的非常重要。他们就是你的咨询师和心理健康专业人士。但对儿童来说，他们是情绪助手。你能多给我们讲讲你在芝麻街工作室的角色吗？作为课程与内容副总裁，你做什么？你是召集这些小组、审查科学研究，还是每样都做一点？好的。因此，作为课程与内容高级副总裁，我的责任是帮助我们的组织弄清楚我们要关注什么。
You know, so yes, we are a school readiness. We're all based on a school readiness curriculum, but then sometimes we have to hone in and put a spotlight on what's going on and being in tune to what's going on in our society. So when we decided that we were going to focus on emotional well-being, I then have a convening. and I have a colleague who's also a senior vice president who oversees our U.S. social impact work, and that's the work that you're going to find on the website. So sesame street.org backslash mental health. And so I help her with her convening. She helps me with my convening because they're very different audiences.
你知道，是的，我们是一个学校准备项目。我们全都基于学校准备课程，但有时我们必须聚焦并将聚光灯投射到正在发生的事情上，并紧跟我们社会中发生的事情。因此，当我们决定专注于心理健康时，我会召开一个会议。我有一位同事，她也是高级副总裁，负责我们的美国社会影响力工作，这就是你将在网站上找到的工作。所以是 sesame street.org 斜杠 mental health。因此，我协助她召开她的会议。她协助我召开我的会议，因为他们的受众非常不同。
So for me, my responsibility is for what we call mass media. So helping the content creators who are writing for the show, who are writing for digital, who are overseeing our publishing department, our licensing department. So messages that are going out there that are directed to children. So child-facing messages with the hope that the adults are going to be co-engaged with them through reading a book or watching the show or playing a digital game or listening to a podcast. My colleague, Dr. Jeanette Betancourt, her focus is the website. And so that's more adult-facing with the understanding that for some content, you want to be able to, an adult may want
对我来说，我的责任是针对我们所谓的群众传媒。因此，帮助那些为节目写作、为数字端写作、监督我们的出版部门、我们的许可部门的内容创作者。因此，发送给儿童的信息。因此，面向儿童的信息，希望成年人能够通过阅读书籍、观看节目、玩数字游戏或听播客与他们共同参与。我的同事珍妮特·贝当古博士（Dr. Jeanette Betancourt）的重点是网站。因此，这更多是面向成人的，其理解是对于某些内容，你可能希望能够——一个成年人可能希望
to bring the child and watch and co-engage in the video. And there's lots of child-facing content, you know, printables and storybooks that are child-facing. But then there's also adult-directed information for the adults in their lives to help them with some of these learning goals. Now, I also mentioned in the intro that you were the co-editor of G is for Growing, 30 years of research on children and Sesame Street. And I'm going to guess that a lot of our listeners have no idea that there's been so much research into Sesame Street and its viewers. And your book was really the first time that this research was examined holistically.
带着儿童一起观看并共同参与视频。这里有很多面向儿童的内容，你知道，可打印材料和故事书是面向儿童的。但同时也有针对他们生活中的成年人的信息，旨在帮助他们实现其中的一些学习目标。现在，我在开场白中还提到，你是《G代表成长：儿童与芝麻街研究30年》的共同主编。我猜我们的很多听众都不知道，竟然有这么多关于《芝麻街》及其观众的研究。而你的书确实是第一次全面地审视这些研究。
I know this was a weighty and serious tone, but could you summarize some of the key findings? Oh, well, that's great. And so that book, that brings us up to, you know, season one to season 29. And I want to mention another book that was co-edited by colleagues called The Sesame Effect. And that book also shows all of the research on our international productions because we are a global educational media company. And in the Sesame Effect, there is a chapter that starts with season 30's educational impact to about season 50.
我知道这是一项分量很重且严肃的工作，但你能总结一下一些核心发现吗？哦，那太好了。所以那书，把我们带到了，你知道，第一季到第 29 季。我还想提到另一本由同事共同编辑的书，叫做《芝麻效应》（The Sesame Effect）。那本书还展示了我们所有国际制作的研究，因为我们是一家全球教育媒体公司。而在《芝麻效应》中，有一章从第 30 季的教育影响一直写到大约第 50 季。
So we're probably the best kept secret. What I mean by that is that a lot of people don't realize the amount of learning science that goes into the creation of our content. The formative research, so as I said earlier, that for us, children are the best experts. So we want to make sure for child-facing content that we're out there talking to showing and talking to children. On the website content, we want to make sure that the content works for caregivers and educators. So formative research is being done with those target audiences. This is a key component of Sesame Workshop's content creation.
所以我们可能是保守得最好的秘密。我的意思是，很多人并没有意识到有多少学习科学被投入到我们内容的创作中。形成性研究，正如我刚才所说，对我们来说，儿童是最好的专家。所以我们希望确保对于面向儿童的内容，我们要走出去，与儿童交谈、向他们展示并与他们交流。在网站内容上，我们要确保内容对看护人和教育工作者有效。因此，形成性研究是在这些目标受众中进行的。这是芝麻街工作室内容创作的关键组成部分。
But it doesn't stop there, right? So we want to make sure the inputs are great for putting out best foot forward in terms of getting an educational impact. But then we're going to do the summit of research, the impact research. And so both books are summaries of the educational impact that we've had, both in the areas of of academic skills, so literacy and language development, math and science, social emotional skills and development, and health. There's a lot of emphasis placed on our physical health. And so both books show you the breadth of the content that we're addressing, but most importantly, the educational impact that we're having.
但它并没有止步于此，对吧？所以我们要确保输入是极好的，以便在获得教育影响方面展现出最好的一面。但接下来我们要进行总结性研究，即影响研究。因此，这两本书都总结了我们所产生的教育影响，无论是在学术技能领域（即识字和语言发展、数学和科学）、社会情感技能与发展，还是健康领域。人们对我们的身体健康给予了很大的强调。因此，这两本书展示了我们正在解决的内容的广度，但最重要的是，展示了我们正在产生的教育影响。
And most recently, which I believe has been released, is that we have done a lot of work in the Middle East with a new co-production called Aham Simpson. And that is to focus on the Syrian refugee crisis. And that work really did focus a lot on emotional well-being. So looking at this research over such a long period, of time. Have you found that kids who grew up on Sesame Street were better in school, grew up healthier, were better adjusted, all of those things that you might want to be able to measure?
最近，我相信已经发布的是，我们在中东开展了大量工作，推出了一部名为《Aham Simpson》的新联合制作节目。该节目的重点是叙利亚难民危机。这项工作确实非常关注心理健康。因此，纵观这么长时间以来的研究。你是否发现，在《芝麻街》陪伴下长大的儿童在学校表现更好、长大后更健康、适应能力更强，以及所有你可能想要衡量的那些方面？
Yes. So there were a couple of seminal pieces of research that were longitudinal research studies, which is really hard to do now. These were conducted in the early 90s, but it showed that children who watched Sesame Street during the preschool years did significantly better in high school. They were able to re-contact those children, children living in Springfield, Massachusetts, and Topeka, Kansas. So that's called the re-contact study, which is in the G's for growing, summarizing the G's for Growing book. What we found with Otham Simpson recently is that, because as we would doing this research. There was a pandemic. And so some of the work had to be moved to digital through a digital device. And they found that the content that was consumed over a,
是的。有几项开创性的研究是纵向研究，这在现在很难做到。这些研究是在 90 年代初期进行的，但它们表明，在学龄前观看《芝麻街》的儿童在高中时的表现明显更好。他们能够重新联系到这些儿童，即居住在马萨诸塞州斯普林菲尔德和堪萨斯州托皮卡的儿童。这被称为“重新联系研究”，它被总结在《G代表成长》这本书中。我们最近通过《Aham Simpson》发现，因为在我们进行这项研究时。发生了疫情。因此，部分工作不得不通过数字设备转移到数字端。他们发现，通过一个，
I don't know, maybe a six or seven week period, was the learning impact was the equivalent of going to school, a physical building for a whole year. So just think about the power of that to deliver our content through a digital device reaching children. This is true for around the world in terms of trying to get to remote areas where children may not be able to get to preschool. So we're pretty, we're very pleased by the results of that study. And it shows the power of our educational content. Make every get-together chill. This Memorial Day, get up to an extra $1,000 off select top brand appliances like LG.
我不知道，可能是六七周的时间消费的内容，其学习影响相当于去学校实体建筑上学一整年。所以只要想想通过数字设备传递我们的内容来触及儿童的这种力量。这在世界各地都适用，特别是试图触及那些可能无法上学前班的偏远地区的儿童。因此，我们对这项研究的结果感到非常高兴，而且非常满意。这也展现了我们教育内容的力量。让每一次聚会都轻松惬意。今年阵亡将士纪念日，购买 LG 等精选顶级大品牌家电可享高达 1,000 美元的额外优惠。
Plus get free delivery at the Huff. Home Depot. Tackle pool towels and camp laundry with a large capacity washer and host and style with the fridge serving craft ice, mini craft ice, cube dice, and crushed ice. Shop Applant Savings now through June 3rd at the Home Depot. Offer valid May 14th through June 3rd, US only, free delivery on appliance purchases of $998 or more. The C store online for details. How do you identify the needs in kids so that you can tailor the right messages at the right time? Well, we're very much connected to the academic community. So I'll give me an example of that, you know, in the early 2000s when all of the focus was on brain development. You know, we learned a lot
此外，还可在家得宝（The Home Depot）享受免费配送。通过大容量洗衣机轻松应对泳池浴巾和露营衣物，并用配备手柄的冰箱来招待宾客，其可提供精酿冰、迷你精酿冰、方形冰块和碎冰。现在到 6 月 3 日前往家得宝选购家电节省优惠。优惠有效期为 5 月 14 日至 6 月 3 日，仅限美国，购买 998 美元或以上的家电可享免费配送。请在店内或网上查看详情。你们如何识别儿童的需求，以便在合适的时间量身定制正确的信息？嗯，我们与学术界保持着非常紧密的联系。所以我给你们举个例子，你知道，在 2000 年代初期，当所有的焦点都集中在大脑发育上时。你知道，作为发展心理学家，我们学到了很多。
as developmental psychologists. And so there was a lot of talk about self-regulation and executive function skills. Well, that was never a part of our school readiness curriculum, right? And so we've learned from the learning sciences that, wow, you know, we need to start focusing more on those process skills. How do children learn content? We've been focusing on the content skills. You know, as you said, letters and numbers and you're, you know, identifying feelings and maybe talk about healthy foods and the importance of exercise. But what are those skills that are the true school readiness skills? And we've learned through the research that it, is those executive function skills, the ability to pay attention, the ability to focus your
所以当时有很多关于自我调节和执行功能技能的讨论。嗯，这从来都不是我们学校准备课程的一部分，对吧？因此，我们从学习科学中了解到，哇，你知道，我们需要开始更多地关注这些过程技能。儿童是如何学习内容的？我们一直专注于内容技能。你知道，正如你所说，字母和数字，你，你知道，识别情绪，也许谈论健康食品和锻炼的重要性。但什么是真正的学校准备技能？我们通过研究了解到，正是这些执行功能技能——注意力的能力，集中你
attention, but also be able to shift your attention and have flexible thinking, the ability to control your emotions that might be interfering with your ability to pay attention. So we revised our whole child curriculum based on those research findings and put those executive function because at the core of academic learning, social emotional learning, and health, health behaviors. Another example is when there was all this focus on STEM education. And a lot of people said, well, Sesame Street can't focus on STEM. You're talking to, you know, preschoolers. Yeah, little kids.
注意力的能力，以及转移注意力和拥有灵活思维的能力，控制可能干扰你注意力能力的情绪的能力。因此，我们根据这些研究发现修改了我们的全人教育课程，并将这些执行功能放在了学术学习、社交情感学习和健康行为的核心。另一个例子是，当所有人都在关注 STEM 教育时。很多人说，嗯，《芝麻街》不能关注 STEM。你在跟，你知道，学龄前儿童说话。是的，小家伙们。
And, you know, that's, that's in, you know, high school, maybe, maybe middle school. And it was like, no, no, no, no, no. preschoolers are natural STEMists. They're scientists, they're technologists, they're engineers, and they're mathematicians. And so once again, we focused on those process skills, you know, the power of investigation, power of observation, the power of analyzing, because they're doing that all the time as they're trying to figure out the world around them. And so we created a STEM curriculum and we have our characters, solving everyday problems using these process skills. And then at the end of the solving of the problem, they're learning a science fact or a math fact or an engineering fact. So those are two examples. It sounds like the researchers are learning as much from the kids as the kids are learning from watching the shows.
而且，你知道，那是在，你知道，高中，也许，也许是初中。当时的想法是，不，不，不，不，不。学龄前儿童天生就是 STEM 从业者。他们是科学家、技术专家、工程师和数学家。因此，我们再次专注于这些过程技能，你知道，调查的力量、观察的力量、分析的力量，因为他们在试图理解周围世界时一直在这样做。因此，我们创建了一个 STEM 课程，并且我们的角色使用这些过程技能解决日常问题。然后在问题解决的最后，他们正在学习一个科学事实、数学事实或工程事实。这就是两个例子。听起来研究人员从儿童身上学到的东西和儿童从看节目中学到的一样多。
Is that true? Absolutely. And I think that's why I've been here for multiple decades because I'm constantly learning. So I have to ask you about Elmo's viral moment on social media a few months ago. Elmo posted a question on X, formerly, Twitter. He said, Elmo is just checking in, how is everybody doing? And he was inundated with replies about people's mental and emotional states. And some people even called it trauma dumping. Were you and the other people at Sesame Street surprised by this moment? We were surprised by the large number of people writing in. That was surprising. But not 100% surprised because we know that we are dealing with a mental health crisis. And not surprised by adults' connection with our characters.
这是真的吗？绝对是的。我想这也是为什么我能在这里呆上几十年的原因，因为我在不断地学习。所以我得问你关于几个月前埃尔默（Elmo）在社交媒体上引发轰动的话题。埃尔默在 X（前身为 Twitter）上发布了一个问题。他说，埃尔默只是来打个招呼，大家都过得怎么样？然后他收到了大量关于人们心理和情绪状态的回复。有些人甚至称之为“创伤倾倒”（trauma dumping）。你和《芝麻街》的其他人在这个时刻感到惊讶吗？我们对大量写信的人感到惊讶。那确实令人惊讶。但并不完全感到惊讶，因为我们知道我们正面临心理健康危机。而且对于成年人与我们的角色之间的连接，我们也不感到惊讶。
And I think that is the power of our Sesame Street. Street brand is that multiple generations now have grown up on Sesame Street. And these characters have meaning in our lives. And so also learning from the developmental psychology research is that when you're a child and you are connected to a character, you develop what we call a power social relationship. Elmo is talking to me. Elmo is my mind. And you know, friend. I can talk to Elmo. Elmo cares about me and Elmo loves me. So think about the people who are on X and social media. They're adults, but they have these emotional connections to Elmo. And by Elmo reaching out, how are you doing? They then revealed how they were doing. And what was
我认为这就是我们的《芝麻街》品牌的力量所在，多代人现在都是伴随着《芝麻街》长大的。这些角色在我们的生活中具有意义。而且从发展心理学研究中学到的一点是，当你还是一个儿童并且你与一个角色建立连接时，你就会培养出我们所谓的准社会关系。埃尔默在跟我说话。埃尔默是我的心声。你知道，朋友。我可以和埃尔默说话。埃尔默关心我，埃尔默爱我。因此，想想那些在 X 和社交媒体上的人。他们是成年人，但他们与埃尔默有着这种情感连接。随着埃尔默伸出援手说“你过得怎么样”，他们随后透露了他们过得怎么样。而令人
wonderful is that we also, because that was a year into our initiative, we now had resources to say, go to Sesame Street.org. We are there for you. You are not alone. We are here for you, and we will always be here for you. I have to ask a question about the early days of Sesame Street, because I grew up when educational TV was just beginning, and it was awful. It was like a teacher standing in a classroom, and the only difference was you were watching on a screen instead of in reality. And it was in black and white. I'm really dating myself here. But then in 1969, Sesame Street came on television, and it was completely revolutionary. Kids loved it and they learned things. What was different about Sesame Street and why do you think it's persisted for all these decades?
奇妙的是，我们还因为那是我们倡议推出的一年，我们现在有了资源可以说，去 sesame street.org。我们一直在那里为你服务。你并不孤单。我们在这里为你服务，而且我们永远会在这里为你服务。我必须问一个关于《芝麻街》早期的问题，因为我是在教育电视刚刚起步的时候长大的，当时它太糟糕了。就像一个老师站在教室里，唯一的区别是你在屏幕上观看而不是在现实中。而且还是黑白的。我在这里真的暴露年龄了。但后来在 1969 年，《芝麻街》登陆电视，它完全具有革命性。儿童喜爱它并且学到了东西。《芝麻街》有什么不同之处，你为什么认为它能历经几十年的风雨而长盛不衰？
A tremendous amount of research went into the design and the making of Sesame Street. First, let's start with our co-founder, Joan Gansconi, who knew that, you know, at the time, she was a documentary producer and focused on, you know, what's going on in terms of the educational needs of children. She wanted to make sure that by creating a television show that we could reach children, in particular children who didn't have access to pre-executive. school education, so the disadvantaged children, and to make sure that giving them an even start, right, to get them ready for school. But because she came from television as a producer, she noticed that young children watching TV, vast wasteland, were able to recite jingles from commercials. And she's like, wow, if we could teach them commercial jingles, think about how we could teach them school readiness skills in little pieces of television. So that was her premise, but she had no idea if this was going to work.
大量的研究被投入到《芝麻街》的设计和制作中。首先，让我们从我们的联合创始人琼·甘兹·科尼（Joan Ganz Cooney）开始，她当时知道，作为一个纪录片制片人，她专注于儿童教育需求方面正在发生的事情。她希望通过创作一个电视节目，能够触及儿童，特别是那些无法获得学前教育的儿童。执行教育，即弱势儿童，并确保给他们一个公平的起跑线，对吧，让他们为上学做好准备。但由于她作为制片人出身于电视行业，她注意到年轻儿童看电视时，在那个所谓的荒漠中，却能够背诵商业广告里的顺口溜。她说，哇，如果我们能教他们商业广告的顺口溜，想想我们可以如何在电视的小片段中教他们学校准备技能。所以这是她的前提，但她根本不知道这是否会行之有效。
And so she got a grant and to say, all right, this is an experiment. No one's ever tried this. Give it a shot. And so she's the one who created this model. We got to think out of the box, as you said, we just can't have a classroom that is just being filmed. We got to get their attention, all right? Just like a commercial gets their attention. So she assembled the developmental psychologist.
于是她获得了一笔资助，说，好吧，这是一次实验。从来没有人尝试过这一点。试一试吧。因此，正是她创建了这个模型。我们需要跳出框框思考，正如你所说，我们不能只拍摄一个正在被录像的教室。我们必须吸引他们的注意力，对吧？就像商业广告吸引他们的注意力一样。因此，她召集了发展心理学家。
She assembled the early childhood educators who know how to create curriculum. And she brought in Jim Henson, right? She wanted to make sure that the street was going to be grounded in reality. It's a real street. We're going to have a human cast, a diverse and inclusive human cast. She wants to make sure that she's reaching all children. But she also wanted to bring in that fantasy. And that's where Jim and his characters came about, right?
她召集了知道如何创建课程的幼儿教育工作者，并把吉姆·汉森（Jim Henson）带了进来，对吧？她希望确保这条街道将立足于现实。这是一条真正的街道。我们将拥有一个人类演员阵容，一个多元化和包容性的人类演员阵容。她希望确保她能触及所有儿童。但她也想引入那种幻想。这就是吉姆和他的角色登场的地方，对吧？
So Sesame Stream is grounded in reality, which is really important for us to hold on to. It remains a live action show. And because it's live action, we can always create content. to meet the current needs of children. So we're constantly evolving and very dynamic. So we're always making show changes. And so get back to your question is like, why are we surviving? Because the show that we created in 1969 is not the show that's currently airing in in
因此，《芝麻街》立足于现实，这对于我们坚持下去非常重要。它仍然是一个真人实景节目。正因为它是真人实景，我们才能始终创作内容。以满足儿童当前的需求。因此，我们一直在不断发展且非常动态。所以我们一直在对节目做出改变。回到你的问题，就像，为什么我们能生存下来？因为我们在 1969 年创作的节目并不是目前在
in 2024, season 54, because we're creating a show that meets the needs of today's children. And I think that's what makes us unique and special. Have kids needs changed over time? I mean, some things are very fundamental and must be the same from generation to generation. But what's new with today's kids? Well, I think there are different things going on in today's world. I think really focusing on emotional well-being is something that's very important. We know that these executive function skills, which children struggle with.
2024 年、第 54 季播出的节目，因为我们正在创作一个满足当今儿童需求的节目。我认为这正是我们独特和特殊的地方。儿童的需求随着时间改变了吗？我的意思是，有些事情是非常基础的，代代相传一定是一样的。但当今的儿童有什么新鲜之处？嗯，我认为当今世界上正在发生各种不同的事情。我认为真正专注于心理健康是一件非常重要的事情。我们知道这些儿童苦苦挣扎的执行功能技能。
We know that these are learned skills. So that was a big change in our curriculum. Focus on physical health. Children don't understand what it means to be healthy. That means I'm not sick, right? But how do you give them these, what we call healthy habits for life? And in terms of academic skills, we're constantly learning about what are best practices. So, for instance, there was a lot of emphasis placed on vocabulary development, right?
我们知道这些是习得的技能。所以这是我们课程中的一个重大改变。关注身体健康。儿童不理解健康意味着什么。这意味着我没有生病，对吧？但你如何赋予他们这些我们所谓的“终身健康习惯”呢？在学术技能方面，我们不断了解什么是最佳实践。所以，例如，人们非常强调词汇发展，对吧？
Remember the $30 million, word gap? 30 million word gap. So we learned a lot about that, that it's, you know, not just showing the letter, what the letter sounds, likes, that's phonemic awareness, but also building vocabulary. And that was important lesson to us, too, when we were focusing on math, that children, while they may have an understanding of math concepts, they may not have the math language. And so there was a big focus on math literacy, and that came out of the academic research. In addition to the show itself, Sesame Workshop has a lot of other avenues to get resources out to caregivers and children.
还记得那 3000 万的词汇差距吗？3000万词汇差距。所以我们对此了解了很多，即这不仅是展示字母，字母听起来像什么，那是音位意识，而且还要建立词汇量。当我们专注于数学时，这对我们来说也是一个重要的教训，即儿童虽然可能对数学概念有所理解，但他们可能没有数学语言。因此，人们非常关注数学素养，这源于学术研究。除了节目本身，芝麻街工作室还有许多其他途径向看护人和儿童提供资源。
Can you tell our listeners some more about the other resources that are available to help kids learn about emotional well-being? Yeah. So as I mentioned on our website, sesame street.org backslash mental health, there's a lot of information that we released and are continuing to release. And so there will be new information coming up in early May. So definitely check back. Yeah, I think by the time we post this, some of that should be up.
你能为我们的听众详细介绍一下哪些其他资源可以帮助儿童了解心理健康吗？可以的。正如我提到的，在我们的网站 sesame street.org 斜杠 mental health 上，有很多我们发布并持续发布的信息。因此，新信息将在 5 月初推出。所以请务必回来查看。是的，我想在我们发布时，其中一些应该已经上线了。
Yeah, so keep that in mind. We also have partnerships. So we partnered with Headspace. And I think this is an important partnership because it also extends the learning on emotional well-being. And so we have this wonderful podcast called Good Night World. We also partnered with Dr. Lori Santos on her Happiness Lab podcast, and so there are three episodes there. And there are other resources in terms of the books that we publish.
是的，所以请记住这一点。我们还有合作伙伴关系。因此，我们与 Headspace 进行了合作。我认为这是一个重要的合作，因为它也扩展了关于心理健康的学习。所以我们有一个非常棒的播客叫《晚安世界》（Good Night World）。我们还与洛里·桑托斯博士（Dr. Lori Santos）在她的《幸福实验室》（Happiness Lab）播客上合作，其中有三集内容。还有其他资源，包括我们出版的书籍。
And we also, on our kid-facing Sesame Street.org, there's lots of digital games and printables and storybooks that I think are also not only resources for, or mental health, but across that whole child curriculum. Our mission at SesameWare Shop is by helping kids grow smarter. So those are those processing skills plus the content skills stronger. Those are the self-regulation and physical health and kinder. We all need to be kinder in today's world. Definitely. Now, you've said in other interviews that young children's mental health
此外，在我们面向儿童的 Sesame Street.org 上，有大量的数字游戏、可打印材料和故事书，我认为这些不仅是心理健康的资源，也贯穿了整个全人教育课程。我们在芝麻街工作室的使命是通过帮助儿童变得更聪明——这就是那些处理技能加上内容技能——更强大——那些是自我调节和身体健康——以及更善良。在当今世界，我们都需要更善良。完全同意。现在，你在其他采访中说过，幼儿的心理健康
is sometimes overlooked in discussions about the youth mental health crisis. Why do you think that is and why is it important to add that perspective to the conversation? Yeah, I think that adults need some guidance and able to pick up on what is going on with their children. So noticing how their children's big feelings might be interfering with their everyday life or there's regression in terms of regression in, you know, potty training, or they may not be interested in eating their favorite foods anymore. So what are those signs or even other distressed signs? Because parents may not always realize that they could be struggling with some mental health issue. And that's why we really wanted to get this next batch of content out
在有关青年心理健康危机的讨论中有时被忽视了。你认为这是为什么，为什么将这个视角加入讨论中如此重要？是的，我认为成年人需要一些指导，以便能够察觉儿童身上正在发生的事情。因此，注意到儿童的强烈情绪可能会如何干扰他们的日常生活，或者在如厕训练方面出现倒退，或者他们可能对吃自己最喜欢的食物不再感兴趣。那么，这些迹象或其他痛苦迹象是什么呢？因为父母可能并不总是意识到他们可能正在挣扎于某些心理健康问题。这就是为什么我们真的希望推出下一批关于
about these feelings helpers. But there are professionals who could help you. And we need to destigmatize this idea that my child needs to see a therapist. Right. Right. A therapist is there to help, not to label, but to help you and the family work together to help the child with their resources to, you know, have a better understanding. For instance, let's talk about anxiety, right? So children who are so anxious that they don't want to go to school or so anxious that they don't want to go to a friend's birthday party or they may not want to go to day camp. I mean, this is an example of you want to be able to help your child so they're not missing out on these wonderful experiences, but they may need some extra helping guidance. So what's the
这些情绪助手的相关内容。但有专业人士可以帮助你。我们需要消除这种“我的儿童需要看治疗师”的污名化观念。没错。没错。治疗师的存在是为了帮助，而不是贴标签，而是帮助你和家庭共同努力，协助儿童利用他们的资源，（你知道）有更好的理解。例如，让我们谈谈焦虑，对吧？因此，儿童焦虑到不想去上学，或者焦虑到不想去朋友的生日派对，或者他们可能不想去日间夏令营。我的意思是，这是一个例子，你希望能够帮助你的儿童，这样他们就不会错过这些美妙的经历，但他们可能需要一些额外的帮助和指导。那么，
critical takeaway you want parents and other caregivers of young children to get from the materials that you're producing right now? Well, I want them to understand that there are a range of emotions and to give children the labels for these emotions to be able to distinguish. It's not just happy, angry, sad, right? There are other, there are other emotion words like disappointed and frustrated and jealous. That's an interesting one. Jealous. What's jealous? But, but, But to connect with your child. So observe these physical expressions of an emotion. Give the child a label, but validate.
你希望父母和其他幼儿看护人从你目前制作的材料中获得的关键要点是什么？嗯，我希望他们理解存在一系列的情绪，并为儿童提供这些情绪的标签以便能够区分。这不仅仅是高兴、生气、伤心，对吧？还有其他的情绪词汇，比如失望、沮丧和嫉妒。这是一个有趣的话题。嫉妒。什么是嫉妒？但是，但是，
Validate the emotion. I understand you are jealous because you are wanting something that your friend has. jealous, what's jealous? And so now you have an opportunity to talk about the feeling. Like, you think you're mad, or angry, but you're really jealous. But then come up with a strategy. How do I be with this emotion? Because all emotions are okay. We all have these feelings. But how do I get beyond, I'm not going to talk to my friend Susie anymore because she's got the sparkly coat that I want, right? So what's a strategy? And that's where these mindfulness strategies come in. And that's where Sesame Workshop comes in because we're not there to tell the
但要与你的儿童建立连接。所以观察情绪的这些生理表现。给儿童一个标签，但要验证。验证这种情绪。我理解你感到嫉妒，因为你想要你朋友拥有的东西。嫉妒，什么是嫉妒？所以现在你有一个机会来谈论这种感觉。比如，你认为你很疯狂，或者生气，但你其实是嫉妒。但随后要想出一个策略。我如何与这种情绪相处？因为所有的情绪都是可以的。我们都有这些感觉。但我如何超越这一点——我不再和我的朋友苏西说话了，因为她有我想要的那件闪亮的外套，对吧？那么策略是什么？这就是正念策略发挥作用的地方。这就是芝麻街工作室发挥作用的地方，因为我们不是在那里告诉
parents what you need to do. We're here to give them the language and the strategies to build our emotional well-being toolbox. So we're there for the how-toes. I often get so upset when when people say, oh, parents need to do this and they need to do that. Well, show me how. Tell me how. And that's where our videos and our resources come in. We're showing and telling how. Well, Dr. Trulio, I want to thank you for joining me today. And I also want to thank Sesame Workshop for collaborating with us. We have a great partnership, and I know it's going to continue. And thank you for this partnership, because we learned so much from all of your experts. And thank you, Kim, for having this wonderful chat today. Really enjoyed it.
父母你需要做什么。我们在这里为他们提供语言和策略来建立我们的心理健康工具箱。所以我们是来教“如何做”的。每当人们说，“哦，父母需要这样做，他们需要那样做”时，我常常感到非常沮丧。好吧，向我展示如何做。告诉我怎么做。这就是我们的视频和资源发挥作用的地方。我们在展示和讲述如何做。嗯，特里利奥博士，我要感谢你今天能来。我也要感谢芝麻街工作室与我们合作。我们有着极好的合作伙伴关系，我知道它将继续下去。感谢你们建立这种合作伙伴关系，因为我们从你们所有的专家身上学到了太多东西。谢谢你，金，今天进行了这次精彩的交谈。真的非常享受。
That's been great. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. speaking of psychology. org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review.
以上就是本期内容。你可以在我们的网站 www. speaking of psychology. org 或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方找到往期的《心理学谈话》。如果你喜欢我们所听到的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评价。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyen. Thank you for listening.
如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温厄曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪恩（Chris Kondyen）。谢谢收听。
For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是金·米尔斯，这里是美国心理学会播客。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。